And back here to Germany, the country's famous Oktoberfest...
…has returned to Munich for the first time since the start of the pandemic.
After a two-year hiatus, the festival opened...
...as the mayor tapped the first keg and the beer started flowing.
The world's biggest folk festival typically attracts millions of people to the city.
Authorities say hospitals there...
…will be able to cope with a potential rise in coronavirus cases.
Oktoberfest runs until October third.
Let's bring in DW correspondent, Benjamin Alvarez Gruber, in Munich...
…standing by at the world's largest beer festival, the Oktoberfest.
Benjamin, in addition to bottomless mugs of beer, I imagine,...
...what's in store for visitors this year?
It's right and the beer, it is already flowing.
There are seventeen big tents and as you can see here behind me.
There are queues of people who started coming to this place...
…even before the doors opened at around nine,...
...so there were people running to get to the tables.
But, of course, for those who are here and don't want to drink beer,...
…want to stay outdoors,...
…there are also many other activities.
There are games, there is a ferris wheel, so there's something for everyone.
If a family, for example, is coming,...
…they can also spend time outside and eat also delicious food.